if you're wondering why I'm standing in
front of this church is because it
allows the worship of multiple gods Yes
you heard that right directly inside of
this church there is a place where you
can worship multiple gods now this
church is heavily centered around Jesus
with beautiful artwork beautiful glass
windows a massive Reverb style effect
due to how big the building is they
allow LGBT preachers and the worship of
multiple gods I actually walked in and I
saw a lady and actually got a
conversation with her I came here a
month ago and I noticed that they have a
place where you can worship other gods
this is completely against the Bible the
Bible that these people in this church
are supposed to be reading from in
Exodus 20: 2-6 it says I am the Lord
your God who brought you out of the land
of Egypt out of the house of slavery you
shall have no other gods before me and
all you know those of you who know
Deuteronomy 64 says the Lord your God is
one and you also know the Bible says
that you know Jesus was crucified he's
the son of God and the place where you
can worship in here contains symbols of
the religion that literally speaks
against that now I'm going to take you
guys on a tour inside so come on with me
and let's check it out
[Music]